synagoge in halle bekommt eine neue türe
ja die alte wurde beim anschlag durch
stephan pariert schwer beschädigt aber
sie hat im angriffe stand gehalten und
konnte so menschenleben retten und der
macher der tür ist mir jetzt live
zugeschaltet tischler thomas thiele
hallo herr tichy
was ist das für ein gefühl das man ja
mit seiner mit einer türe die man
gemacht hat menschenleben gerettet hat
grundsätzlich auch mal ein tolles gefühl
im ersten moment war mir das gar nicht
so richtig bewusst was dort passiert es
also in welcher in welcher dimension
sich das verhalten hat das kam stück für
stück ins bewusstsein und ja ich bin
absolut stolz drauf und glücklich dass
unser handwerksarbeit das volk
verhindert hat dass hier menschen in
größenordnung ums leben kommen und was
passiert jetzt mit der alten tiere die
alte türe die soll als mahnung gedenkt
mal ausgearbeitet werden von einer
jungen künstlerin hier aus halle und die
wird im bereich der synagoge vor bleiben
und was ist an der neuen tür jetzt
anders die neue tür ist eigentlich
grundsätzlich vom optischen her erst mal
das gleiche wie die alte hier haben wir
lediglich mehr sicherheit eingebaut das
heißt die hat eine mehrfachverriegelung
die zusätzliche sicherheit bringt durch
neben schließt stellen
die hat stabilere bender sie hat einen
zusätzlichen stark erhalten und ist im
gesamten noch ein stückchen massive
millimeter stärker gebaut als die alte
das schloss hat eine panik funktion so
dass im notfall auch aus der synagoge
heraus geflüchtet werden kann
das hat nur im vorfeld leider nicht
dankeschön thomas stehle für diese
information vielen dank